let's start uh by looking at some of the
specific examples of uh Claudine Gay's
apparent plagiarism this is from that
article that January 1 article I
mentioned um where you put side by side
some of her writing next to a scholar
named David Canon and uh we can see by
the highlighted material here I'll just
for our audio listeners I'll just read
that first highlighted paragraph David's
Canon version is is uh the V is often
cited as one of the most significant
pieces of civil rights legislation
passed in our nation's history claudi
gay writes the Voting Rights Act of 1965
is often cited as one of the most
significant pieces of civil rights
legislation passed in our nation's
history then it goes down on to describe
the central parts of uh this uh of the
Voting Rights Act and it's almost
identical language
um one other example I'll pull up here
Claudine gay and Gary King side by side
Gary King writes the posterior
distribution of each of the precinct
parameters within the bounds indicated
by its tomography line is drived by the
slice it cuts out of the barar uh B
variant distribution Claudine gay writes
the posterior distribution of each of
the precinct parameters for Precinct is
derived by the slice its tomography line
cuts out of this byari distribution so
these are fairly technical descriptions
of uh kind of political um political
districting and so forth and
legislation and my understanding is that
she uh did not even you know often
people will put in parentheses I'm
citing this person or a footnote or
endnote she didn't put any of that but
she did cite these people in their
bibliography so what um
you know what should we take away from
these these are just a few select
examples but of the the many examples
that you have compiled of plagiarism in
her
work well it's a Continuum of severity
right and even your own examples I think
show that um the more technical example
that you mentioned with the bivariate
distribution
um
that's not ideal but I think she could
plausibly say that that was at worst
mildly sloppy and at best kosher because
her argument and the argument some other
social scientists have made is that at
when you're describing very technical
methods or even describing the terms in
an equation which is not quite what
she's doing there but it's close uh
there's only so many ways to to describe
an equation or describe a very technical
model in social science so it's hard to
avoid redundancy it would be unrealistic
to
site every single time there's some
redundant technical verbiage um you know
that is a common argument people have
made it's not an argument that is
incorporated into
Harvard's uh plagiarism policies for
students those policies don't make any
kind of exception for technical language
but if you're looking at this relative
to the Norms of social science
scholarship ah I think you could defend
some of those examples um the one that
you put on the screen with David Cannon
I think is harder to defend because it's
not technical language it's also uh much
more extensive right several par several
sentences um which if you actually look
on the page of her book that that's from
comprise almost half of the half a page
of material um it's stuff that yes there
maybe aren't that many ways to word the
technical ins and outs of the Voting
Rights Act but still there's so so many
of those sentences are just copy pasted
it's pretty hard to argue that she
couldn't have changed at least a few
more words uh or or or moved some things
around that I think is more you know
again taken in isolation is at the end
of the world no but it's it's a more
severe case
relatively and then the most severe case
that uh I don't think you put on the
board but is worth mentioning um it's
from a previous article I wrote is when
she
copied um pretty much an entire
paragraph uh verbatim from uh two of her
colleagues in the Harvard government
Department um Bradley Palmquist and
Steven Voss without not only without a
uh quotation marks or without citing
them in parenthesis but without listing
them in her bibliography anywhere so
that was a pretty clear-cut case that
one of just straight up plagiarism that
I don't think anyone could really defend
or argue was anything other than
plagiarism and in fact that that is one
of the passages that she uh corrected um
uh she she added quotation marks in the
citation after being called on it um so
there's really a spectrum here um but
there's a lot of examples that fall on
various parts of the spectrum so even if
you think that maybe 25 even 30 40 of
the examples are minor there's still 40
of those examples plus maybe 6 to 10
more severe ones and you're looking at a
pattern how egregious do you think this
would be in
Academia if gay hadn't been in her role
as president of Harvard if she were just
an academic and the Scandal came out and
it wasn't colored with all of these um
sort of political under and overtones
how do you think academics would treat
her
well we have some Clues based on how
Harvard has treated former cases like
this from just regular professors um and
what they've typically done is either
not punished them or has said yes they
plagiarized but it wasn't that big a
deal so we're not going to punish them
at all right or the to the extent there
is a punishment it's merely the sort of
official determination that plagiarism
took place but there's no actual uh you
know material sanction
like being censured in Congress right
like that doesn't actually much it's a
symbolic slap on the wrist right so that
happened to Larry tribe and I think a
couple other professors over the past
two decades um it's Alan DT Larry tribe
there's one other law professor and then
uh Jill Abramson same thing happened and
in all of these cases the professors
basically
apologized and in a couple cases the
university said yeah they did Technic
plagiar
eyes you know that's unfortunate but
they didn't really do anything about it
um so if she were just a tenur faculty
member the normal response would be for
her to
forthrightly say yep Maya screwed up
sorry and then the university did not
really do anything um of course a as you
say she's not a normal 10y faculty
member she's the president of the entire
University and B
she did not do what those other
professors did which was to own up to
their mistakes and for everyone to just
acknowledge yeah it was plagiarism but
you know not the end of the world uh
instead she and the Harvard corporation
uh retained a really high-powered Law
Firm Clare lock to try to suppress the
story with a defamation threat to the
New York Post um you know employing
these really Cloak and Dagger tactics to
just prevent it from ever coming to
light uh and then after we published a
story
you know and and it became hard for them
to ignore they say well it wasn't
plagiarism it was just inadequate
citation or duplicative
language uh blah blah blah blah blah
euphemism
Galore and and and in the course of
investigating the allegations the
university did launch its own probe they
did not go through the normal processes
uh outlined by the research misconduct
office they just basically appointed
these unnamed political scientists to do
this very not opaque non-transparent
investigation totally outside of the
norms and processes Harvard has laid out
to do this kind of
probe so when you look at the response
in some ways the cover up is worse than
the crime um they really I there's never
been another professor in Harvard's
history where they've employed anything
like these tactics to try to suppress
the story um or then to downplay it when
it could no longer be suppressed and I
think that you know that that is a real
difference right my and my understanding
is uh correct me if I'm wrong she is
still employed at Harvard and drawing a
significant salary even though $900,000
a year or something seem like that and
that's not even counting the speaking
fees that one can draw later on right
like that's not even the once the yeah
once the examples piled up uh you know
she resigned the presidency but uh not
exactly taking a huge hit financially
there there there's one more example
that was the
most kind of uh amusing and alarming one
to me which was documented in the New
York Times uh where she copied the
acknowledgements from yes a uh of in her
1997 Harvard dissertation she uh copyed
the acknowledgements from a another one
of her Harvard colleagues of political
science Jennifer hosch child wrote uh
Sally jensx showed me the importance of
getting the data right and following
where they lead without fear or favor
adding later that M Mr jenx drove me
much harder than I sometimes wanted to
be driven sorry that was Sandy jensx and
then uh do Dr Gay uh thanked her thesis
adviser who reminded me of the
importance of getting the data right and
following where they lead without fear
or favor and then thanked her family who
drove me harder than I sometimes wanted
to be driven
I mean what do you do you have like a
theory of mind for what is going on here
is this just like she's producing so
much content that it's just like she's
grabbing from wherever she can to put
these manuscripts together like what do
you have any insight as to what's going
on
here yeah I mean maybe she just felt
like she needed to have an
acknowledgement section but was crunched
for time before filing
her dissertation um yeah and was
cribbing in the way He suggests I have
to say you know it that example on one
level is more minor because it doesn't
involve plagiarizing any kind of
substantive scholarly language certainly
doesn't involve plagiarizing an idea but
on the other hand it does seem to be the
example that
has Disturbed the largest number of
people including I think members of the
Harvard faculty you know I I can't name
names but I I I've been told by multiple
professors at Harvard that
that particular example
really bothered them um because it just
seemed so gratuitous so hard to
rationalize right you know the
acknowledgements are supposed to be
these deep personalized heartfelt
expressions of gratitude and here you
are cribbing a stock phrase from
somebody else it just really rubbed
people the wrong way way so so even
folks I think who were inclined to
dismiss some of the allegations as
either politically motivated or simply
not that big a deal just seem to think
that this one indicated
something negative about her character I
think the best you can say is that she
was rather lazy um and the worst you can
say is that maybe there was a kind of
almost
pathological inability to come up with
original
language um even to thank your own
mentors
um and yeah you know I I don't I don't
think that that single
example would have made all the
difference but I it is interesting to
run the counterfactuals right in which
you subtract this or that given example
and that does seem to be one of the
examples that really mve the needle for
quite a few people um so it's possible
that without that simple copying uh that
one instance of copying maybe she
survives this probably not but uh that
one really seemed to upset people in in
my conversations in a way that a lot of
the other ones did not hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcaster